esta es la frontera de bolivia y perú
según fuentes oficiales acá llegan cada
día alrededor de 400 migrantes haitianos
tras cruzar el territorio boliviano
desde brasil una travesía llena de
dificultades que incluye extorsiones de
parte de algunos policías corruptos
según la denuncia de ronald peters
bolivia está maltratando a los haitianos
eso de eso en todos los lugares por los
que pasamos ellos nos piden dinero es
pecado
si uno no paga 20 dólares 50 no nos
dejan pasar
ronald es uno de los migrantes
afortunados porque consiguió pasar al
lado peruano al contrario este año más
de 5 mil haitianos fueron detenidos en
bolivia y deportados en su mayoría hacia
brasil 5 mil 418 personas hubieran
pasado por el territorio nacional de
manera irregular estas personas han sido
intervenida
tras las críticas al maltrato el
gobierno ha firmado un decreto que
permite a los haitianos quedarse en
bolivia por dos años pero la mayoría
solo quiere seguir su camino hacia perú
una solución consistiría en darles
visados humanitarios para evitar que
sean expulsados hacia las fronteras por
eso es importante considerar esta
temática y ya en fondo dentro del estado
a través de la amnistía a través del
aviso de tránsito a través de la visa
humanitaria pero principalmente en la
región para que los estados comprendan
que cierre de fronteras se está
generando delincuencia en este momento
unas soluciones que sin duda habrían
ayudado a ronald ya sus compatriotas a
cruzar por bolivia sin problemas sin
embargo los operativos policiales
prosiguen contra migrantes haitianos en
su travesía hacia perú otro hito en su
ruta hacia eeuu